- Hello everyone, good afternoon.
It gives me great
pleasure to invite you all
to our discussion session,
a more in-depth discussion of
the talk we heard yesterday
from Dr. Elise Crull.
And as part of the
Inference Colloquium series,
as many of you know, we
have these two events.
We have the talk followed
by a more open discussion
with the issues that
were raised in the talk
and yesterday Dr. Crull talked
to us about causal ordering
and in particular, the many
phony issues that come together
when one is trying to
understand quantum entanglement
and the role of causal ordering
in understanding quantum
mechanics more generally,
and she presented some new ideas,
new avenues that she's been
thinking about on this problem.
And it gives me great pleasure
today that our discussant
and conversant with her,
we have Professor Yemima Ben-Menahem
from the Department of Philosophy
at Hebrew University of Jerusalem.
Yemima Ben-Menahem is the
Barbara Druss Dibner Professor
of the History of Science Emeritus
at the Hebrew University of Jerusalem
and a lecturer in the
Department of Philosophy
and Jewish Thought, Shalem College.
Professor Ben-Menahem, to
those of you who are familiar
with the intellectual currents
and the philosophy of science
would know that needs no introduction.
She's one of the preeminent
philosophers of science
whose work has found causation,
the interpretation of quantum
mechanics, scientific realism,
the role of contingency
and necessity in history.
So real broad pallet
of really important and complex problems
that she has worked on.
And so she is the perfect conversant
from whom we can learn a lot
about how to think about
these sort of radical new ways
that Elise presented yesterday
for us to engage with the
concept of entanglement.
Professor Ben-Menahem's recent book
titled "Causation in
Science" published in 2018
is truly remarkable.
So if any one is looking for a primmer
to get to speed on matters of causation
in science, more broadly,
including the many open
questions and debates,
I highly recommend the book.
And before I turn the
floor over to Yemima,
I would like to invite you and remind all
to keep your video switched off.
And just a quick reminder on the format,
we will cede the floor
to Professor Ben-Menahem
after which Elise and she will engage with
going through for the points
of clarification and debate
and then we open up to the floor
for a general Q and A.
So without further ado,
I would like to turn it over to Yemima.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you very Priya for this invitation
and thank you Ty and the
people who are here with us.
And I'm really grateful
to Elise for introducing,
and I suppose many of us are,
for introducing us to
really cutting edge thinking
in the foundations and experimentation
and for the thinking and experimentation
in the foundations of quantum mechanics.
Actually I won't be
discussing superposition
of causal states and processes
that she presented to us yesterday,
but I want to step back a little bit
and go back first to
a few words about quantum mechanics
and then step back even further
and talk a little more about causation.
So quantum mechanics is mind-boggling,
we all know that.
And the price we have to pay,
well, the benefits are enormous too,
because it's the most
successful theory ever.
But the intellectual price
we have to pay seems to rise
with every new generation of
researchers looking into it.
Because at the beginning we only thought,
okay, Schrödinger's function
doesn't describe a wave
in three dimensional space,
it's a probability wave, okay.
So maybe we have to give up determinism,
but that's not such a high price.
But then it turned out
that there are much more serious problems
and one of them and perhaps
the most serious problem
as Elise noted yesterday is
the problem of entanglement.
And the reason it is
such an engaging problem
and such a difficult problem
is that it threatens
to get us into conflict
with a special theory of relativity,
which no one really wants to give up.
So, this is the major problem.
There are other problems,
the measurement problem,
other problems, and there
are various solutions to it
and none of them completely
satisfies everyone as yet.
But I want to go back for a minute
to entanglement and how it came...
I have to...
I thought I was sharing the screen.
So we have the uncertainty principle
and Einstein and his
colleagues, Podolsky and Rosen,
was looking at this uncertainty principle
which gives us a kind of
limit on what we can measure
or how precisely we can prepare a system.
But there was a camp in,
well, mainly the Copenhagen Camp who said,
no, this is a much more serious constraint
and it has a limit on,
not only at the precision
that we can measure something,
that we can prepare a system,
but on the actual existence
of these variables.
And there are certain pairs of variables.
And initially, and we here too
can talk about position and momentum.
So what was...
And if we have only one particle
and we're going to measure its position,
how are we going to prove
that it didn't have a
momentum at the same time?
We cannot do that
because when we measure a
position as Heisenberg showed
we interfere with the momentum
and so we cannot prove that
the uncertainty principle
is really such a strong
constraint on reality.
So the ingenious idea
was to take this system
and have two particles
instead of one particle.
And then at the beginning,
they start from a position
which we can designate by zero
and zero momentum as well.
And then there is some interactions
that sends them into reverse directions.
And now the story begins.
We can either measure position
and then the other party would know,
and I'm specifically not
specifying at the moment why
the other party would also know
what position the particle is in,
although no measurement was
carried out on the other side.
But we could also measure momentum
and the other party would know
and since we didn't interfere
with anything that the other party did,
Einstein and colleagues concluded
that both position and momentum exist
and the only limitation of
the uncertainty principle
is on measurement.
Okay, why do I go to that problem?
I go back to that problem
because already here,
why is it that we assume that
the momentum of one particle
has to be correlated with
it of the other particle,
because there is a conservation law here.
So already here we touch on something
that according to my approach,
and I will say more about it
later, is related to causality.
Now, as thinking about that developed,
a lot of things had to happen.
First of all here we
have continuous variables
then Bohm translated it
into discrete variables
which would lead to measurement,
then the famously Bell translated
it or not translated it,
but reformulated the problem
when we don't only measure
variables in one direction,
but we play around with the correlations
in different directions
like three different spin measurements
in different directions.
And moreover, it turned out
that we can send these particles,
initially turned out that
in theory we could do that.
We can send these particles
so far away in space time that they are,
as we say, spacetime related
and they cannot interact with one another,
according to the special
theory of relativity.
And then the correlation
becomes really mysterious
because how are we to
explain that correlation?
They cannot signal to one another
because we saw to it
that they're so far away.
So the only other possibility is
that there is a common
cause to this correlation.
The only other possibility,
given our classical way of thinking.
When we have correlation,
then either one is a cause of the other
or the other is a cause of the first
or if that cannot happen,
if there cannot be a direct
connection between the two,
we are looking for a common
cause for that correlation.
And the big achievement
of Bell's inequalities
was to rule out the possibility
of such a common cause.
In this context we call the
common cause hidden variables,
because supposedly there are
some additional variables
that determine what would be
the result of a measurement
on each one of the particles
in each one of the directions
that we choose to measure.
So, instead of common cause
we are talking about hidden variables,
but it amounts to the same thing.
And so if there is no common cause
then we're back to the
problem of correlation.
So maybe they do signal to one another,
but that would mean that we're violating
the special theory of relativity.
So this is a big conundrum,
and as conundrums are sometimes solved,
there is a distinction.
These dates can be correlated,
but they cannot signal to one another.
And this is a new idea because, again,
classically, we would
think that the correlation
lets us or allows us to infer
from what happens to one,
what happened to the other.
But in this case we say
correlation, yes, signaling, no.
So it's a new way of
understanding the correlation
in order to save compatibility
between quantum mechanics
and the special theory of relativity.
Now, the especially theory of
relativity, as you remember,
is a causal theory in a very strong sense
because there is a limitation
on how causal signals can travel.
They can travel at just certain speed,
not faster than the speed of light.
And therefore it is causality
that divide spacetime
into regions where events in those regions
can interact with one another causally
and regions that where events
cannot interact with one another causally.
And moreover, in those events,
in those areas of spacetime
where there is no causal interaction,
there is no well defined temporal order.
So just in parenthesis,
you remember you thought
he could define causation
in terms of temporal order,
in terms of regularity
and in a way special relativity
reverses the order and says,
we know what a causal signal
is and how fast it can travel
and that will tell us in
which areas of spacetime
we can talk about the
definite temporal order.
So, the problem of entanglement
and the compatibility
problem that it raises
confront us with two aspects of causation.
One is that it is conservation laws
that explain for us the correlation,
we don't want to violate
certain conservation laws,
and the other is that we
worry about the conflict
with a theory which is
cause of through and through
in a very strong sense.
And as I will proceed to explain,
I don't think there is one sense
to the notion of causation,
but the theory of special relativity
is a causal theory in a very strong sense.
So, what can be done about this?
So, a number of thinkers,
I'm thinking primarily of
you Bryce, have come up,
but he was not the first one
and he is not the only one
and I have one of his...
Has a nice formulation
of quantum mechanics
that is similar to what Bryce had in mind
and he's a physicist philosopher.
So instead of talking about particles
and their correlations,
we can think analogously
about two twins and they're...
This is, again, very familiar.
It's not my translation
into this scenario,
but they are presented
with a series of questions
and we find that their questions...
So somewhere in their future,
there is someone asking
them these questions
and we find that their answers
are more correlated than we would expect
if they'd had just answer randomly.
And so we say, well, we have
here some kind of correlation,
it's not random.
There must be some common cause.
So probably the twins have
kind of genetic property
that ensures they're
replying to certain questions
in a certain way.
Now, according to what we just said,
those inequalities and the
whole problem of entanglement
is that if we assume such a common cause
or we assume such hidden variables,
we get into conflict
with quantum mechanics.
And the violation of Bell's
inequalities were confirmed
by experience many, many
times since the eighties.
So if that's not a possibility,
if we cannot go on the left
schema of a common cause
to the correlation between the two twins,
their new prices, why don't
we go in the other direction
and suppose that by
asking these questions,
the questioner causes
or acts upon the twins,
making them, giving them the property
that will yield the
correlation between them.
So rather than looking for
a common cause in the past,
we look at something in the future
that who's influence goes back
and explains the correlation.
So this of course is a very radical idea
because we haven't encountered
anything like retrocausation
in our daily lives.
And so this possibility sits there
and I want to ask later
whether one takes it to be
only an epistemic possibility.
If we know what the answer was,
we could go back and
calculate probabilities,
or if this is supposed to be something
about physical reality.
But anyway, it's a very radical solution.
And what we heard yesterday
is certainly a kind of spinoff
from that route of that
approach where we say,
look, why are we so tied
to the classical picture
where the past influences the future,
but the future never influences the past.
Perhaps we should give up this assumption.
So should we give up causal asymmetry
or temporary asymmetry?
Because the two are related and as I said,
sometimes we see causation is
parasitic on temporal order
and sometimes it's the other way around.
There's in special relativity, I think.
So according to Bryce, according
to some other philosophers
and according to Elise yesterday,
this is indeed a lesson
which we should draw.
And her approach wasn't
based on Bryce's argument
or on retrocausality,
but it was based on these
very recent arguments,
theoretical arguments and
very recent experiments
that seem to suggest,
I almost say demonstrate the experiment,
but let me be very
careful, seem to suggest
that this is really a very
fruitful approach to take.
And I want to emphasize that the idea here
to relinquish the causal
order between past and future
applies both according to
Bryce and according to Elise
to the fundamental level of physics.
And there're other philosophers
who've argued in that direction
and I think even Carlo Roveli,
the first lecture of the series
which I listened to with great pleasure.
So we're talking about the
fundamental level of physics
and say, here, there is no
temporal direction or no,
or no causal direction.
And the question of why
we get the impression
that there is such a thing
on higher level is a very big question.
And I think we should get to that question
in the discussion.
So this is one thing I want to note
about yesterday's suggestion
and the other thing is more important
because you see there was this argument
for years and years and years,
that the fundamental laws of nature
are time reversal symmetric.
They don't distinguish the
fundamental laws of nature,
do not distinguish
between past and future.
No error of time at the
fundamental level of physics.
But I always felt that there
was a gap in this argument
and to conclude from the
time reversal symmetry
of the fundamental laws,
that there is no temporal
order in individual processes,
seemed to me a big jump,
because it couldn't be
that all processes can go from
one direction to the other
and also from the other
direction to the first.
Like we can blow a balloon
and fills up with air
and then we deflate it
and it's, again, this
little piece of rubber
and both can happen,
but in each individual case
we could think, supposedly,
in each individual case we can say,
by pointing to initial conditions
of whatever we could say,
what the direction in
this individual case was.
So it seemed to me that there
is a gap in the argument
from time reversal symmetry
of the fundamental laws
to no temporal order on
the fundamental level
or no causal order on the entry level.
And what I found so fascinating
about the results that
Elise presented yesterday
was that here we talking
about individual processes.
We're not rehearsing this older argument
about the fundamental laws.
And yet, we should note that
the asymmetry in question
is but one of the characteristics
traditionally associated
with the notion of cause.
So even if we give up this asymmetry,
this doesn't mean that we
give up causation in general.
So giving up the asymmetry
of the causal relations,
a temporal asymmetry
of the causal relation,
doesn't mean that we must
give up the notion of cause.
And here I get to my first question.
So, into both(chuckles),
imagine it's causation.
I know Mark Twain speaking to you
and the reports of the death of causation
are greatly exaggerated on my view.
So why is that?
Can you hear me?
- Yep.
- So here comes my first quick question
and it goes to you Elise,
but it goes to other people
who've written about it.
Are we talking about the
principle of causality?
I think you mentioned such a principle
in your talk yesterday,
or are we talking about
the concept of cause?
And so just to show you
that people confuse it too,
and later in the discussion
maybe I could explain why.
So here's Russell.
The word cause is so inextricably bound up
with misleading association
as to make it's complete extrusion
from the philosophical
vocabulary desirable.
And that is after criticizing
the principle of causation.
So he concludes, no principle no concept.
And much more recently,
Joe Norton, of course says,
centuries of failed attempts
to formulate a principle of causality,
robustly true under the introduction
of new scientific theories,
have left the notion
of causation so plastic
that virtually any new science
can be made to conform with it.
So I think it's a big exaggeration.
It's not so plastic.
It's not so easy to construct a new theory
that follows constraints
that you wanted to follow
or to satisfy.
But what I pointed here
is a confusion between the
principle and the notion.
And I don't know what the
principle of causality is
in the sense that there are
at least two formulations
of the principle of causality
and they're not synonymous
and they're not even co-extensional.
So, but again, I skipped
that and I can answer.
I can explain why I'm saying
that later in the discussion.
But anyway, I don't want
to suppose that we endorse
or uphold the principle of causality.
What I do want to suppose
or to propose, well, first.
So now there are many
definitions of causation.
There is a vast philosophical literature.
People are working on causation
and whether it's a human definition,
whether it's David Lewis's definition,
whether it's energy transfer,
whether it's a probabilistic
definition of causation,
many competing definitions in the field,
but they all refer to the causal relations
between individual events.
And each one has its problems
and each one can be patched up,
but I don't want to follow
this well-trodden route.
What do I want to suggest?
I suggest, I have suggested it already,
I cannot pretend that it just occurred
to me yesterday after Elise's talk.
So I suggest looking instead
at more general constraints,
which in my view comprise
the notion of cause.
So what is a causal constraint in my view?
A causal constraint is
a constraint on change.
It tells us which changes
and processes are possible
or even necessary, and no
less important, in my view,
which changes are impossible.
And if you go back to the
philosophical literature
about causation, for example,
Woodward interventions,
this sort of thing,
then they're often very good
at explaining why something happened,
but they're not so good
at explaining why something didn't happen.
And I think that in
science it's crucial for us
when we think that something can happen,
but we never find it.
We never find two electrons
in the same level.
We want to know why.
And it's a methodological principle
that we should find a law or a constraint
that excludes this option
that we thought was possible,
but we don't find it.
And that's why I think the
language of causal constraint
is much better to explain
what doesn't happen.
And I think it's crucial for science
to think both about what happens
and about what doesn't happen.
- So, Yemima, I just have
a quick clarification.
So a causal constraint
then by this definition
is intimately related to the
idea of the counterfactual.
Right or?
- It is but you know,
this is not the basis of the definition
because there are definitions
of causation(indistinct).
A cause is a necessary condition,
which means that if it hadn't happened,
the effect wouldn't have happened.
But I'm not saying that.
I'm saying a conservation
law is a causal constraint.
(indistinct)
So, yes, if we wouldn't have
the conservation of energy,
we could build a perpetual mobile machine.
So almost everything we say
supports some counterfactuals.
We say something positive
and it supports some counterfactuals.
And I'm for counterfactuals,
I have no problem with
counterfactuals, even in history,
but this is not the definition.
This is not the defining characteristic.
But perhaps we should pause for a moment
on this notion of change,
because you know from antiquity,
philosophers have argued like
for many just saying there's
no change in our guide
to saying everything is changed.
You cannot step into the same river twice.
And we today have a kind of sense of this
between those views.
We say, yes, there is change in the world,
but not any change.
We have constraints on change.
Why do I think that this
is important for physics?
Because unlike mathematics,
there're mathematical constraints
in physics, of course.
But the physical constraints
that are not mathematical in my view
are constraints on change.
Mathematics doesn't
have a notion of change.
And so I think everything
that governs change,
don't take the metaphor of
governing too literally,
but everything that tells us
which changes are possible
and which changes are not
possible has to do with causation.
Now, I know that I'm vulnerable here
to what Quine used to say,
by denying the doctrine one
only changes the subject.
So in a way change the subject
because I'm not talking
only about causal relations
between events and I want
to broaden the picture,
but I think I have motivated
my wish to broaden the picture
and I'll say more about it in a minute.
So examples of constraints
and I want to emphasize that
none of them is a priori,
we have to check in each theory,
whether the theory
satisfies this constraint
and we check it empirically.
So we don't impose our constraints.
But there're constraints
that have gained our presence
and we rely on them and we use
them to build new theories.
There are symmetries that we
use to construct new theories.
We trust the symmetry
and we think that our theory
should be generally covariant,
or we think it should follow
some other symmetries principle
of relativity or whatever.
So here are some examples of constraints.
Determinism, locality.
And, again, I emphasize
they can be disproved.
Maybe the fundamental theories
are not deterministic.
Maybe some theories are,
some theories are not,
but there are constraints
that have been used
and that we should consider
and that are part of the
cluster notion of cause.
The other one is locality.
We've talked about this at the beginning
and yesterday, of course.
There're symmetries and conservation laws,
which are very important.
They are high up in the
hierarchy of physics.
There's Curie's principle,
which tells us that every
symmetry in the cause
has to be in the effect,
but it uses causal notion,
so we can formulate it in terms
of equations and solutions.
We can formulate it in various other ways
that do not presuppose
the notion of course.
We have invariance
principles which are, again,
very high up in the hierarchy
of physics symmetries,
and invariance principles
and there is a connection between them,
but we don't go into that.
And stability sometimes, not always.
It's very important.
I think the notion of stability,
like the notion of
necessity and contingency
is very important in human life.
Again, I'm not stopping to
discuss this notion here,
but just remember that
when Bohr was struggling
to construct a new model of the atom,
he had to comply with
what we know about atoms,
that they are very, very stable
and the classical model
wouldn't give him the stability
and therefore he had to assume
all kinds of assumptions
about stationary state,
they do not radiate,
et cetera, et cetera.
So sometimes stability is
also of course a constraint.
And these constraints I've
dealt with in my book,
but there are other
constraints that are...
In any way I didn't think in the book
that I had something very
new to say about them
and I was also indecisive about them
and one of them is causal asymmetry.
So one reason I didn't want
to spend much time on it
in the book was that Mathias
Frisch just published,
a year or two years earlier,
a book entirely dedicated
to causal asymmetry,
and the other reason
was that, I don't know,
I think it's too open at the moment.
How much of a constraint is it?
It's not something that usually
would be considered a constraint
that would tell us what kind
of theory we should construct.
It's not like the principle of relativity.
It's not like least action.
It's not like these
well-established principles.
And yesterday we heard
of very recent reasons
of why it's not just such
a fundamental principle.
And there is another interesting principle
and it may even be somehow
related to this principle,
which is a mutuality of causal action,
which means that if here we
are talking about events,
if the cause act on the effect,
the effect also act on the cause
and you could say this
is Newton's third law.
And in that case it's
certainly a causal constraint,
but Einstein used it as a justification.
Even if it was a
justification after the fact
for justifying dynamical spacetime.
Because he said there was
something very unsatisfactory,
causally unsatisfactory in Newton theory.
Because here in Newton
theory we have space
and space act on matter
because acceleration relative
to space has physical meaning.
But we don't have matter
acting back on space.
And in my theory, in general relativity,
we have matter acting back on space
so this restores the symmetry.
So this was the line of
argument in Einstein in 22,
wasn't mentioned in 1922,
wasn't mentioned in the 1916 paper.
So it may be something that
occurred to him afterwards,
but again, it's a kind of constraint.
Sometimes we think it's
a marriage of a theory
if it's a "basic, but it's not
something that fundamental.
Okay. So why the causal
constraints approach?
Why do I prefer it,
although it has this problem
of changing the subject somewhat?
So first of all, I think
this is how scientists think.
I think very rarely scientists think
about the case of two people
trying to murder a third one
and one punches a hole in the water flask
and the other one puts poison in it
and then whose responsible
et cetera et cetera.
This is not the kind of question
that worries scientists,
but scientists want to worry...
They want to know about basic symmetries,
basic invariance laws.
So I think there are more
useful to think about
in the context of scientific reasoning.
There're also historical reasons,
because if you think of
it, conservation laws,
there were ancient ideas
about not creating anything
for X helio, so to speak,
and that nothing gets
lost back into the void.
So there was this idea of conservation.
There was an idea that the
cause equals the effect.
So in some sense they're historical root
to the idea that conservation
laws are causal constraints
and you have people like
Mason and even Bohr.
When Bohr talks about causality,
he actually talks about conservation laws.
And, again, I won't go into it here
but at least probably knows
because she writes a book
or she has written a book
on the history of quantum mechanics
and other philosophers,
like, I mean Madison also thinks
the conservation laws are very,
so there are historical reasons.
There are, as I said before,
causal constraints explain
what we do not find
and that's an function
of a causal constraints,
but the fourth reason for me,
and this does not depend
on changing the subject,
it's not a semantic issue
and that this approach
of the causal constraints
opens a variety of questions
about the relations between
different constraints.
So, when we only have one
definition of causation
and we think that's the
definition, et cetera,
we don't think very much
about the other definition,
but when we see that
we really have a family
of several constraints
and some perhaps are more
fundamental than others.
Some perhaps are reducible to others
and some perhaps we tend
to confuse and we shouldn't
and then there is a lot of work to do.
So, some of these
relations are well-known.
For example, cemeteries and
conservation laws are related.
It was already, people became aware of it
in the course of the development
of classical mechanics
and then of course they are the important
theorems of EMI nature.
So symmetries and conservation laws
are closely related, this is well known.
There are other cases,
there are things that we seem
or conceive of as very closely related
and they are not so closely related.
For example, determinism and necessity
or determinism and stability
or again in more everyday
talk, determinism and fatalism.
There was a big difference
of whether one event is very stable
and no matter where you start,
you're going to get to it
or whether we just have determinism.
And, there is another option also,
we want to disentangle
determinism and necessity
and stability.
This is also a nice case
where we should disentangle notions.
Again, in the philosophical literature,
you'll have a definition of causation
in terms of actually determinism.
But then there is a competing definition
in terms of intervention, right?
Causal model theories
are based on this idea of intervention.
Now, when you think of it,
when does determinism apply?
Determinism only applies
in a closed system
and intervention is always
an intervention from without.
So, actually there is a tension
between causation as intervention
or as manifesting itself
in a case of intervention
and determinism where
you have a closed system
and once the initial conditions are given,
nothing can change.
And so when you think about
the different members of this
family of causal constraints,
you can be more sensitive
to these differences.
And there are cases, and here
we get to quantum mechanics,
where there is really a
very fascinating dance
between different constraints
and a dance or pair of relation
that was not evident from the beginning.
And if we go back to the EPR
situation that we started from,
which gave rise to the
idea of entanglement,
here we have a very
peculiar pair of relation
between determinism and locality
because it turns out that
the reason we can comply
with the no signaling constraint
that gives us compatibility
with special relativity
is that neither Elise nor Bob
can predict the results of the
measurement with certainty.
So it's because when they
look at what they do,
they cannot infer with certainty
what the result at the other end was
that there is no signaling.
Because if there was determinism,
they could have used the
correlation that they know
in order to signal.
So here we have an example of,
you think of it, locality
is one constraint
and it talks about how causal inference
spreads in space-time,
which would be continuous, et cetera
and it would take time
and determinism is something else.
It tells us that if we
have the same system again,
it will develop exactly
the same trajectory
and on the phase of it,
we don't see the relation between the two
and in classical physics
it's not clear how this relationship works
but in quantum mechanics, it's
a very intricate relation.
So, we can now go back
and we may discuss several questions
and I want to say something
about the last of these.
And so, these are not,
we don't have to discuss them
but these are just suggestions
for what we could discuss.
So I asked Elise yesterday
and I would like to hear more about it,
how she characterizes her view
vis-a-vis these other views
that claim there is no cause of direction
on the fundamental level of physics,
in particular there is no causal asymmetry
at the level of quantum mechanics,
so if and where this view differs
because the metaphysical part of the talk,
I wasn't so sure that I'm following
the point where you
think these new results
really make a difference
to what the other people who
said there is no causal order,
no temporal order on
the fundamental level.
I wasn't sure that I
see the exact difference
between your conclusions,
from the experiments and from
the theories you reported
and the point you were trying to make.
The other question,
which we didn't discuss yesterday,
but you mentioned at least
the possibility of an
epistemic interpretation
of what we see.
And I wanted you perhaps,
if you'd like to expand
a little bit on that,
would it make a difference?
What kind of difference would it make?
Epistemic interpretation
of quantum mechanics
are quite influential
and I wonder whether you want
to say a bit more about it,
I know you mentioned it yesterday.
The third one is whether free will
is particularly problematic for any view,
here I wrote retro-causation,
but in general, for every view that allows
an influence from the future to the past.
I deleted apparently question number four
because we started to
discuss it yesterday.
And so the last question to
me is the most troubling one
and I want to say something about it.
And the question is
how does causal order
emerge on higher levels?
Because we agree that on
higher levels, we do see,
I suppose you would agree to that
and we do see temporary order
and we do or we seem to see,
we have an impression of temporal
order and of causal order
and we want to know if not
how they actually emerge,
how our impression has been formed
and has become so stable
that we say, well, it's
our intuition or whatever.
It has become a very
stable kind of thinking
that something like that
exists on higher levels.
And why do I think it's a big question?
Because we don't know as yet very much
about the relationship
between quantum mechanics
and the higher level of physics.
Let's say quantum mechanics
is the fundamental theory,
let's forget for a minute
about general relativity or whatever.
Let's say quantum mechanics
is the fundamental level,
on the fundamental level,
there is no causal order,
there's no temporal order.
How does it emerge?
So, I'm not talking about
why entanglement disappears
in the classical work,
because there is a good question to that
and you mentioned it yesterday
and your work is,
some of your work goes into
decoherence in great depth.
So, decoherence explains to us
why we don't see superposition
in the macro world
and that's fine,
but this is not my question
because causal order,
causal asymmetry and temporal order
somehow emerge again, either in reality
or in our perception of reality
and we want to know how that happens.
And that brings us back to
their time, thermodynamics
and answers to that question
and I think sometimes
there are good arguments
but very often there is
a lot of hand-waving.
We live in the macro world
and here the second law
of thermodynamics applies.
Well, we know that's not enough.
So we say yes,
but our universe is such that
the initial conditions were such
and we are the result of this branch.
We're sitting on that branch
that started with these
particular initial conditions.
And, again I'm not sure this
is a very satisfactory answer
and that it really explains
the mixing of coffee and milk
as we say in our cappuccinos.
So, what am I looking for?
Why am I dissatisfied?
I want to give one example
that to me is a paradigm
of a wonderful case
and that's Feynman's derivation
and with that I would
conclude, it's my last point.
And this is the kind of
idea that I want to set
for explaining the relationship
between quantum mechanics
or the fundamental level
where there is no causal order
and the higher levels where
there is a causal order.
So, Feynman succeeded to recover,
in recovering the
principle of least action
from his picture of quantum mechanics.
And if you think of it,
there is something very
surprising about that
because the principle of least action,
and I said at the beginning,
variation principles are
very important in physics,
so there are very, very high up
in the hierarchy of causal constraints,
but the principle of least
action and it's likes,
it's a very strange
principle if you think of it
because Newtonian
mechanics is okay, right?
Every particle, every mechanical object
gets instructions every minute
and these instructions
determine how it would move.
But a principle like the
principle of least action
seems very teleological, right?
Because how can a system
pick a particular path
that at each point satisfies
a constraint of economy
or minimal value to a certain integral.
It seems that it has to
have the end point in view
and choose a path that does something
and this is ridiculous, this
is completely teleological
and we want to get rid of
this kind of formulation
in physics, right?
So, okay, then people prove
that the principle of least action
and the formulation of classical mechanics
in terms of Newtonian
differential equation
or equations are equivalent
and we can view it as either
completely causal under Newton,
or teleological with the
principle of least action
since our equivalent,
we don't have to place too much weight
on either of these perspectives.
The causal list will say that
teleological explanation
is a superstructure
on the causal explanation
and if someone likes
teleological explanation,
you would reverse a picture
and say that the cause of structure
is a superstructure on the
teleological structure, fine.
But then comes quantum mechanics
and it's all probabilities,
certainly according to Fanno.
How can we recover the
principle of least action
with this teleological appearance
from the underlying chaotic
reality of quantum mechanics
and Feynman managed to do it
and there is a calculation,
there is a derivation.
He had a hint from Dirac
as to how to define action
in quantum mechanics,
what is the analog of classical
action in quantum mechanics?
He was looking for it for a long time
then he got this hint from a student
who came over from Europe
and told him about it
and within hours, as they
say, this is a story,
he derived the Schrodinger
equation, et cetera, et cetera.
So he formulated quantum
mechanics in Lagrangian terms
and in terms of the
principle of least action
which was his favorite formulation anyway,
even in work that he did before.
So this for me is a model
of deriving something
macroscopic and curious
and inexplicable on the
phase of it in quantum terms
and to derive it from the underlying
reality of quantum mechanics.
So, what I would like to see,
not that I'm hoping for
one of us to do it tonight,
but I think this is a model
that would not be just hand-waving.
We sit here in the microscopic world.
Yes, We sit in microscopic world
we're worthy of the relation.
We have to find some continuity
between this fundamental level,
which there is no causal order
and the higher levels on which there is.
So, any of these points
or other points that you
want to react to Elise,
I'd be delighted.
- Well, thank you so much Yemima.
There's just so much goodness there.
I wrote notes and notes and
notes while you were speaking.
So I will say very briefly
and then sort of respond
to a couple of things
and then let others weigh in
and we can see where the discussion goes,
what people find most interesting.
But the first thing I wanna say is that
I find your definition of causality
as a constraint times change,
to be I think among the
most robust definitions
I've encountered
where causality is not
at the fundamental level.
Indeed constraints are not,
they're sort of meta properties, right?
They're properties about
how properties can be
and I find it extraordinarily helpful
and so I really like it.
But what I think
indefinite causal ordering
experiments are doing
is putting to test what
happens when we drop
a sort of our, what we assume
to be the correct constraints
for the loose ordering of certain events
or certain operations
and what they find is actual fruit, right?
Not just that,
not just greater efficiency in
quantum computation perhaps,
but there's also a suggestion that
it may guide how we think
about quantization of gravity
by thinking about these things.
So, in a way, and somebody
had asked yesterday,
I think it was Fext or maybe it was Peter,
how I moved from decoherence to this.
Well decoherence is exactly
the rich studies that come out of that
are based on realizing that
we only do quantum mechanics
in the first place,
as you said Yemima,
by invoking certain assumptions
or idealizations about the
closeness and isolatedness
of the system of interest
that we can carve the
world up in certain ways
and this is the apparatus and
this is the system of interest
and there's the environment
and we can neglect the
environment and so on,
and we can pretend that
Schrodinger's equation
really univocally evolves, right?
And unitarily, right?
Univocally and unitarily.
So there's deterministic aspects there,
but that's not true.
Anytime you have an interaction,
you have non-unitary terms introduced.
So I think, even if I
agree with you totally,
which I do about this
definition of causation,
there's two things,
the one is that, well,
one of the arguments
for maintaining a robust
understanding of causality
at higher levels,
and I take it that you said you disagree
that there is no causal
principle you think, right?
No universal causal principle,
I think we agree about that,
that seems pretty clear.
The question then is, okay,
how do we get usefulness
for the clearly useful,
clearly fruitful higher level concepts,
but at the same time,
the fact that it is by dropping
the concept of causality,
by dropping a presupposed
background dependence
on a particular structure.
So for instance, change.
Change requires that you
parse up the phase space
in a certain way
and look at how the system
moves through contiguous cells
in that phase space.
So ICO, I take it,
people investigating this
are trying to develop theories that
do not presuppose any
parsing of phase space
or any parsing of that space.
So they still measure change
but the change they're
measuring is sort of relative.
It isn't an ultimate,
it isn't based in some
structure of the world
that's truly causal or has true
different split time points,
which is exactly what
Einstein, as you mentioned,
why he rejected Newton's
absolute space-time cathedral,
or the theater in which
these events happened.
He wanted to drop that absolute background
and let the laws of physics
sort of work within that
and I think that that's
a similar question here.
So that's the first thing
is that thinking about causal
constraints could be useful,
but also how we can get
around those constraints
or untether the way those constraints
are more to particular
parsings of space and time,
because that's where we get change,
could be very fruitful too.
So that's that point
and then I'll end with
a metaphysical point,
which is again, constraints,
they can't be primitive, can they?
I mean, our constraints of
brute fact of the world,
it seems they couldn't be
because we have counterexamples
like spontaneous symmetry breaking,
or I don't know, parity,
failure in beta decay.
It seems that our symmetries
and there's a lot of
literature about this,
which I'm not totally
up on and you may be,
but symmetry isn't gonna be
our guiding light either.
And there is something-
- They are or they are not?
Sorry, they are going to be
or they're not going to be our guidelines?
- They cannot be, I think,
because of these counterexamples.
So they are very useful heuristics,
they are very important for modeling
and even for developing new theories
but they're useful as guides
but problematic is dogma, one might say,
and if you were talking about
what does the world really look like?
I think constraints,
you either have to accept
them as a brute fact,
the world just as the way that
such that momentum is conserved,
or you say, there's
something deeper going on.
And in this way, maybe the debate here
is a little bit like Brown
and Pooley and others
with their Lorentzian pedagogy.
It's like what do you
count as a brute fact?
Is it Lorentzian variants
that's a brute fact of universe
or is it the way the metric is?
And that sort of
explanatory story you tell
about how physics,
how the other theories
sort of rely on that
under that underpinning,
depends on what you want
to accept as a brute fact
in your metaphysic.
So, yeah.
Thank you.
And I wanna think a lot more
about the retro-causality
thing, I hadn't yet.
I had taken Hue's work to be sort of
not directly targeting the asymmetry,
but if he is targeting
the asymmetry argument,
then I'm clearly aligned in
some ways with what he's up to.
So I will have to take a deeper
dive into that literature.
Thank you.
- Great. Thank you so much.
- Can I have a quick(indistinct).
- Yeah, sure, please go ahead, yeah.
- Yeah, well, I think
I try to make it clear
that I don't see any of
these in a dogmatic way.
I don't see any of these is a priori.
I think our knowledge
of the world develops
and our notions, our explanatory
notions develope with it.
We didn't have a notion
like general covariance
before Einstein's general
theory of relativity
and then we have this notion.
And what is beneficial?
So I'm not dogmatic about any of these
and of course we learn
that some laws do not apply
and if you only think about
the history of the conservation of energy,
so his topic was mass has then developing
and we don't know now what is dark matter
but I can tell us more about it.
So we don't know where
conservation of mass energy
would lead us in the future.
These are open things in our
eye, it's an open texture.
Science is an open texture
and our causal notions are open texture
and perhaps we'll drop
some of the constraints.
Perhaps we have dropped determinism.
I mentioned determinism,
but it's not that I think that determinism
is still an accepted constraint.
So sometimes we benefit
from adding constraints
like when Einstein said,
I don't like it that matter
doesn't act back on space.
Let me add this constraint,
it should act back.
Then it has dynamical space-time
and background independence and wonderful.
So he added the constraint
or general covariance.
On the other hand, we gain a
lot from dropping constraints,
like dropping determinism.
Some people say drop compatibility
with special relativity, whatever.
So it can work in either way.
And the last thing I wanted
is to be dogmatic about it
but to the contrary,
I want you to say there
is no one definition
of causation that a philosopher can give.
It's the way science develops the terrace.
Now, whether it's a brute fact,
I don't know what brute facts are,
unless you want individual fact.
There is what they call in
philosophy, human supervenience.
All the reason the word are the track.
And then there are our
most economical ways
of summarizing up these.
I'm not sure that all laws of nature
like conservation of energy, for example,
although it is, as I said,
the future of this law is open.
I don't think we understand them
as a summary of what happened.
We want to say,
don't invest in building a
perpetual mobile machine,
it won't work.
There is some kind of
stronger necessities,
and just the summary of the facts.
So I think constraints are viewed by us
in a different way than facts,
but it doesn't mean that
they're not fundamental.
I don't know of anything more fundamental
in physics than some basic symmetries,
but it's all the feasible.
Tomorrow we may prove wrong.
- Okay, yeah.
I'm sorry if I suggested
that you were being dogmatic.
I think I was sort of
imagining metaphysicians
who would take your project
on board and want to motivate
like a robust sense of causality higher up
and deny fundamental causal
that they end up sort of reifying that
causal constraint notion.
- No, no, no.
- But yeah exactly.
And I think I said this yesterday too.
I mean you're very clear in the book.
By the way, pick it up, everyone.
(Yemima laughs)
- Thanks for the promotion(laughs).
- But you're not primarily asking
metaphysical questions of the sort,
but clearly you and I are both interested
in the emergence kind of question
and where that emergence
begins and where it ends.
Well, where it ends is obvious,
it's at the observable.
But where it begins will matter
on your metaphysical construal of things.
To some extent I might
think, it does for me.
- I can't separate metaphysics
from size that much.
Certainly not when I'm
not thinking about ethics,
but about causation.
I think we learn from science
what the world is like.
And I don't think that
I have some other means,
some access to a metaphysics
which I can judge,
whether it's right or not to
help me understand science.
I think it should be bottom up bias
to look at what science does
and see whether it makes sense
in some more general way
that you could learn,
that you would count or that
other people have counted
as metaphysics.
Causation usually in philosophy
belongs to metaphysics
but to me it belongs to
philosophy of science.
- Fair point(chuckles).
- So that was wonderful.
There are a couple of questions
that we have from the audience.
And one is from Jen Gary
who ask would degradation
of signal to noise
be another example of a constraint?
- That's how the quantum
switch folks do their work.
It is exactly...
I saw that in the chat.
Jen, that's exactly spot on.
They are thinking about
signal to noise constraints
in a particular way here.
I need to understand
better how that works,
but Yemima is that
something you encountered
in your research for the book?
- No, and in what sense
is it a constraint.
You want to limit it, no?
It's something that you want to reduce.
It's a programmatic, is it a
pragmatic idea to reduce or?
- Sorry. I can let the...
Yeah, Jen if you wanna answer that,
you'll probably do a better
job than I can(chuckles).
Oh, and cybernetics, I see.
Well, noises, I mean it's related
to the fidelity of the qubit
and some sort of the cleanliness of the-
- By the way it has do with information,
like how do you pass information.
Right? Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you can think of the ICO(indistinct)
which has being about establishing
various quantum channels
and quantum channels is all
about signal to noise ratios,
as far as I understand.
- So what would the constraint look like?
And can I...
That we should reduce the entropy
or the loss of information
to a certain degree
and that one, two channels
are more efficient
than classical channels in doing that, or?
- Huh, let me see if I can remember.
It has to do on how they calculate
the upper and lower bounds
for that process matrix,
the causal witness.
So it's packaged right in at the front
and that's part of why I
wanna dig into this more
because the physics in this case
is not very clearly
telling us what's going on.
So yeah, it's how they measure
the noise to signal ratio
allows them to set those bounds
on when the causal witness is witnessing
a group of events that
are separable causally
or non separable causally.
So their whole definition of separability
or entanglement as it were
non separability entanglement
is based in the signal to noise measure.
- I see.
So I think Jen follows
up with another question.
So in law human actors perform acts
without thoughtful action or intention.
Well I knew this one about
free will was coming.
What might be the connection
between this precept and freewill?
- Well, I think we both wanted
to leave open the fact
that there're robust
and genuinely not just useful
but explanatorily weighty
and maybe even predictive
notions of causality
that emerge in, for instance, biology,
evolutionary biology, or what have you.
But, yeah, I guess if there is some
notion of reduction plight,
if you wanna understand
what the basic behavior of the
smallest bits and bops are,
then it seems that you do have to add...
I have assumed a quantum fundamentalism
and that's that I,
yeah, it should be clear
like that is an assumption.
I think I'm in good company
in making that assumption.
- [Man] But that's a different point.
- Yeah you are.
You are in good company but
I am not in that company.
Can I say something about that?
- Yes please, yes.
- Just a sec.
There's a difference between
the quantum phenomena
and the current somewhat
confused understanding
of the quantum phenomena.
The anomalies in that understanding
are not essentially anomalies
in quantum phenomena.
So you have a lot of theoreticians
talking about quantum
phenomena in different ways.
And some of the anomalies in theory
are anomalies in talk about quanta,
not talk about not the phenomena,
not the quanta themselves.
So you're presuming to
over come, to offset,
to sabotage some classical
ideas of causality
as energy transfer for example,
just on the basis of
ideas in quantum theory,
which explain experiments that
are incompletely understood.
So an incomplete understanding
of quantum phenomena
is producing ideas of
causality that offset
or undermine ideas of causality,
which seem fairly well grounded in
thermodynamics or biology.
- Yeah, no, I disagree with this.
- (indistinct)evidence.
I mean, for instance,
the first ICO switch test
that was done by(indistinct),,
like they developed a system
for doing a computation
that was more effective
when they built it this
way than the other.
So that cries out to me as a philosopher,
says there's something
here worth explaining
whether it turned out as an
anomaly or not is further,
but Yemima sorry, you have been
waiting patiently(chuckles).
- Yeah, no, no.
Well, I certainly don't want to
throw away robust causal notions
in the classical level on to the contrary.
I think my constraints work
well in classical physics,
but many of them, even
if not the causal order,
as I emphasized,
that I'm willing to be
open-minded about the causal order
in view of these new experiments,
but there are more symmetries
and conservation laws
in quantum mechanics than
in classical mechanics.
So I think in this sense,
some of the constraints are
satisfied in quantum mechanics
so I don't think quantum
mechanics is in a causal theory
or theory which has no causality.
Maybe, then this is what Elise
the question at least opened our eyes to.
Maybe there is no causal order there.
But then the more important
question is reduction.
I'm not a reductionist.
I think in order to have reduction
we have to translate the
laws of the higher level
into the laws of the lower level
and the concept of the higher level
to the concept of the lower level.
And the idea is that once we do that,
everything will be explained,
but it doesn't work that way
because we learn that very often,
a lot of the properties
of the higher level
are completely insensitive
to things on the lower level.
And therefore it is
preferable to use properties
and concepts of the higher level
to explain phenomena that
happen on the higher level.
So I'm not a reductionist.
And this is also related
to the problem of free will
because in order to
have an explanatory law,
we have to explain the explanandum
that is the phenomena
that we want to explain.
We have to describe it
in a way that matches the
description in the law.
If we want to explain
why this boat is sunk,
we have to use the
weight that it can carry
and the weight that was put on it
and it will help us understand
why it couldn't float.
But the name of the captain
and the shirt he had on,
that day won't help us.
So we have to have the right description.
And I think that a lot of the properties
that we need for mental activity
are not physical properties.
Physics has nothing to
say about all the people,
the group of people whose
name begins with a B.
It's not a natural kind.
So we cannot expect that physics
will have something to say
about that group of people
in the way it has something
to say about electrons.
And in the same sense,
I don't think that
physics can say something
about all the things in the
words that can be frightening.
There is nothing common in physical terms
to all the frightening things.
So I think even in a deterministic world,
there is some sense of freedom
in the sense that we cannot explain
and therefore we cannot
predict our actions
because the description of the action
doesn't match any natural kind
that a law of physics can be
hooked to or hooked on to.
And it's the very limited sense of freedom
and I think it may connect
well with what you said,
but even in this limited sense
is consoling because it can even
be realized in a deterministic world.
And we don't know that our
world is deterministic,
but even in a deterministic world,
we can have that kind of non
reductionism and freedom.
- [Man] Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
So there's a question from Jenny Wagner,
another of our regular seminar attendees.
And she asked to question number two,
how do you interpret the
Pauli exclusion principle
as a causal constraint?
Can two electrons never actually be
in the same state ontologically?
For me, I would be cautious
and say that this should only
be interpreted epistemically
because we can never prove
this exclusion principle.
So should we treat possible
and impossible constraints
in different ways?
- Thank you very much for this question.
I suppose it's to me.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so Pauli's principle
is really an interesting principle
because in its mature formulation,
it's just a mathematical principle.
The wave function of this combination
is to be anti symmetric
and from that everything else follows
about fermions in general.
And I had a big argument with
a very dear colleague of mine
who died at the beginning of
the pandemic of COVID virus.
And he said, Pauli's
principle is a demonstration
that purely mathematical principles
do work for us in physics.
But I looked a little more into
the history of the principle
and its applications.
Not so much the history,
but the application of the principle.
So there was a very nice application
of the principle early on in 31, 32,
I don't remember exactly, by Chandra Sikka
who calculated the mass of a white dwarf,
the limited mass beyond
which it would collapse
under its own gravity.
And so there is gravity pulling inside
and what is a force that pulls outside
and it's really the result of
Pauli's exclusion principle.
And only when gravity
overcomes that pressure
towards the periphery,
when gravity overcomes it
and pulls the mass back,
then we have the collapse.
And the limited reach,
which I think is around
1.4 of the mass of the sun
is still very much a pre-op
if it's still accepted.
- Not very much there,
I mean and (indistinct)
pressure is a real thing
and also you know in the laboratory
when they make both Einstein condensates,
they're taking advantage
of the degeneracy pressure that you get.
So these new states of matter and stuff.
- Okay, so in that sense here
it works like a causal principle
because it's something
that balances gravity.
So gravity, again, is very abstract
and Pauli's principle is very abstract,
but the applications of these principles
are applications to very concrete things.
And then later, many years later
then when they prove the
mature form of the theory
and they had to prove it,
they used what they call micro causality.
That is relativistic, special
relativistic principle
that parallel or
analogous to no signaling.
So, again, a causal principle
went into the proof of the theory.
So even if electrons for us
and other fermions certainly
don't have an identity
and we cannot track them and
find them in a certain place
and say the other one
cannot get into this place.
The way that principle
works and is applied
is I think in harmony
with I considering it a
causal principle assymetry
and anti symmetry to causal constraint.
- Thank you, that was a very nice,
and that was a great example, actually,
very impressed.
- In your area,
I'm so glad-
- I was gonna say(indistinct).
Remembered one point for solar masses.
That was great.
So are there any other questions.
If not I'd like to close
with one question myself
and I think that...
I wonder, when we talk about determinism
and we talk about reductionism,
I often have a difficulty
trying to see how they sit conceptually
with like the essential
sort of provisional nature of science.
And that I know that the provisionality,
so what I'm trying to get at
is the provisionality of science.
What is knowable in nature
has two kinds of limits.
So there may be limits that
are intrinsic to nature itself
that maybe it's not
knowable beyond whatever.
And the other is our own
kind of cognitive limitations
and tools and capacities.
So I was wondering how our
notions of reductionism
and provisionality kind of,
I mean do they collide or
do you see them, you know,
how do you both see them?
I would love to hear a little bit more
about how to think about them,
because these are sort of conceptually,
I struggle with them
actually, I have to confess.
- Where exactly do you see the connection?
Why should someone's position
on determinism dictate
position on reduction?
As I said I think we don't
have to be reductionists.
- Well, I think that because
they conflict at the point of prediction
about what kind of predictions
therefore you can make for
future behavior of systems.
So if you have a deterministic system,
then you are able to predict fairly well,
although limited with current limits
of how much is knowable, right?
- Yeah.
- Reductionism is...
I see the way reductionism matters
is there is a way in which
you can map one system
or one set of problems onto another one,
which is predictable,
which was deterministic,
even though this particular
one might not be.
I'm trying to search
for a concrete example,
but I'm not as sharp on
the fly as you are Yemima
to come up with a problem that
would really illustrate this.
- Well, I think it's related to models
when you take one area as
a model for another area,
and, as I say,
determinism only applies
under very strict conditions
of close systems.
And even if determinism
holds in the classical world,
you know there arguments
that it doesn't even hold
in the classical world.
- Classical world, right.
- Yeah, like Newton and
airman given examples,
but I think the examples are very far out
and we don't have to take
them too much into account.
So let's say, for us the
world is deterministic
and then we learn that there
is a more fundamental level
of quantum mechanics, which isn't,
then, again, I think it's...
Our methodological drive is to explain
how what we see is compatible
with what we know about
the fundamental level.
And that in some cases we succeeded,
in some cases we do not.
You know, phase transitions.
It's such a complex area
we're trying to figure all
these phase transitions
from what we know about
the fundamental level
and we learn a lot of curious
things about analogies
between different materials
that behave in similar ways
although it's not the same mechanism.
- [Priya] Hmm.
- Magnetization is not the
same mechanism as condensation,
but it's a similar mathematical structure
and similar fixed points.
And so it's not a reduction
to the mechanisms of the
fundamental level at all
and not a reduction.
And determinism,
I don't think I have to answer
those questions together.
Determinism is a different issue
from reduction.
- Elise did you wanna weigh in?
- Yeah, I agree with what Yemima says,
but maybe from a slightly
different perspective,
I mean the way I could
maybe understand reduction
and determinism is the
same as that they're about
establishing a particular
kind of relationship
between two relata, a before and after,
or cause effect relationship,
in the case of determinism
or a higher order, lower
order for reduction.
But my PhD thesis was all about,
if this depends on a well-defined relata,
then you don't get, there
are no well-defined relata,
unless you're assuming
closed isolated system,.
And this becomes
exacerbated at large levels
and this is why you get maybe
as James Ladyman has said,
like you get maybe an ontology for biology
that's appropriate to that field of study
and that genuinely explains and so on,
but it doesn't reduce
to quantum mechanics.
- It is not translatable to quantum.
- Yes.
- Right.
Thank you.
Are there any other questions.
Last questions from the audience.
I don't see any,
so I would like to take this opportunity
to thank both Yemima and Elise
for wonderful session today
and for a really nice lecture yesterday.
It was a real treat
and I personally could
have had this go on(laughs)
longer and longer.
Hang on to both of you
and the kind of ask many more questions.
It's really remarkable how sharp
and clear your understanding
is, both of you.
- [Elise] Thank you so much.
- Thank you very much.
Real pleasure, real pleasure
and thank you Elise.
I'm so glad we met at this
very nice opportunity.
- Yeah and I hope Yemima,
we are hoping to have
a workshop next year,
hopefully, the virus permitting.
Hopefully we will see you in New Haven.
- Oh, wonderful, thank you very much.
I'm looking forward to it.
- And I just want to say thanks to Ty
and to Guy and for our
audience for attending.
Thank you everyone, bye.
- Thank you.